Colt and Scott,
in this competition
we were inspired by
history's legends.
Now we ask that you continue
to be inspired by history's
legends as we send
you back to your home
forge to make one of these.
Excalibur!
It's actually not Excalibur.
The sword in the stone
is a medieval broadsword.
Good luck, bladesmiths.
We'll see you in four days.
SCOTT: Today, I'm making
a European broadsword.
I'm going to do two
types of twisted masses
going opposite directions and
a linear bar for the center.
I am very happy to be back home.
I know that I have all the
proper tooling to do stuff very
quickly, but I think
it's going to be
a very challenging competition.
It's the end of day one.
I got the twisted masses done.
I've got to cut them to size
and then clean up the edges
that I'm going to reweld.
That's where it's at right now.
I'm feeling pretty nervous
going into the clench,
really hoping I don't
get any warps or cracks.
Oh, [bleep].
COLT: It's taken a warp.
I'm really struggling here.
I'm bending it, seeing
if it will straighten.
I'm heating it up with
a torch and trying
to drop water droplets
on it to see if I
can set it back into shape.
I finally get this warp out
by taking my pair of tongs
and pushing down on the sword.
That straightened
it out a little bit.
Trying to fix the warp
really set me back,
but tomorrow I'm going to
come in with a fresh mind
and see what I can get done.
SCOTT: Yesterday was
really productive.
I got the three
bars of Damascus put
together, forged out to a sword,
and then I got it ground down.
Today's most important thing is
getting that heat treat done.
If I can get it done early,
I can focus on the handle
for the rest of the build.
It's pretty straight, and
it definitely heat treated.
I'm just going to clamp
it while it cools.
I thought I had the
heat treat right,
but unfortunately
after I pull it out,
it's got a nice warp in it.
Oh, [bleep].
It looks like I might
have to heat treat again.
The one difference is I'm
going to use my quench tank
as my temper oil.
I'm going to get the oil
up to the same temperatures
as I would the oven,
to about 450 degrees,
then hold my sword in it
for at least 10 minutes
so it gets a nice soak.
Pull it out of the quench, and
it comes out almost perfect.
All I have to do tomorrow
is fit and finish,
guard, handle, pommel.
COLTON: The theme of day
three is handles and guards.
All that needs to
be done is etching
and sharpening on the blade.
I'm going to acid etch
the blade now, let it
sit in there for a few minutes.
So the top of the blade
is not hardened as much
as I would like it to be.
I want to make
sure that it's not
going to take a bend or a set.
It seems to have
held up pretty well,
so the last thing I need
to do is the handle.
It's the end of day three.
I have the finished blade.
I've got the guard fit up.
The handle is shaped
like I want it.
All I have left to do is
the pommel, and it's done.
SCOTT: Beginning of day
four, I'm ready to get
the sword finished.
First I need to get
the holes drilled
on the guard and the pommel.
And that's all I need.
It's looking pretty good.
End of day four, this
broadsword is built,
and I am ready to go
have dinner with my wife.
All right, bladesmiths,
welcome to the kill test.
It's time to get medieval
on your broadsword.
I'm going to take your weapons,
deliver some slashes and blows
on this ballistics dummy.
Colton, you're up first.
You ready for this?
Yeah.
Let's have fun.
COLTON: I'm feeling
confident about my sword,
but I really don't know
what could go wrong.
I've never made a sword before.
[music playing]
That thing was sharp.
DOUG: All right, Colton,
first up, I really appreciate
the balance you have
with this because it's
easy to wield with forward
slashes, back hands,
and thrusting with it.
Your edge is sharp.
Now your handle, it's
just a little bit too tall
for me in the tense
of it's wider here.
But I can still get
a good grip on it,
and more importantly, this
sword, with its balance,
it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, Scott.
It's your turn, sir.
You ready?
Yes, sir.
DOUG: Let's do this.
I'm ecstatic to see
Doug playing with my sword
because it's
exciting to see what
it can do to the human
body, what it's built for.
[music playing]
All right, Scott.
First up, that is
beautiful to look at.
Thank you.
DOUG: Now the wire wrap
does give me some kind
of contours to hold onto.
Every slice-- or
should I say chop--
dug deep into this
ballistics dummy.
Overall, the kind of weapon and
damage you can do with this,
it will kill.
Thank you.
All right, gentlemen.
It's time for the strength test.
Now to test the strength
and overall construction
of your blades, we have
the battering-ram chop.
Colton, you're up first.
You ready?
- All right.
OK.
I'm worried that my
blade is almost too light.
I made this blade for slicing,
not chopping trees down.
[music playing]
So Colton, there's
some definite issues
in the heat treat.
Right here at the guard,
you picked up a bend,
and it's not a warp.
This sword is now bent.
And also up here where
the sword is the thinnest
right at the end of the fuller.
It's a beautiful piece,
but that's a major problem.
That's severe.
Does it feel like it
could continue testing?
I wouldn't.
I mean, it's like a gun
barrel that's already curved.
I don't want to fire something
like that if it's not extreme.
If it's here, it's one
thing, but it's all the way.
It starts at the handle.
Yeah, I mean, it's already
failed as far as I'm concerned.
I'm seeing the judges talking,
and it's nerve wracking.
All right, Colton, there's
a problem with your blade.
The judges have given your
blade a vote of no confidence.
In other words,
it held together,
but it's not safe to
move forward in testing.
That doesn't mean that
you've lost this competition.
Scott, your blade still has to
hold up in this strength test.
Dave?
SCOTT: I am very nervous.
I am very, very nervous.
I don't know how
it's going to do.
All I can do is trust
that I built it correctly.
[music playing]
So right off, Scott,
everything's solid and tight.
All in all, I think
you did a great job.
Nicely done.
Thank you.
Colton, unfortunately for
you, this means that your blade
doesn't make the cut, and you
cannot be the "Forged in Fire"
champion.
For that reason, I'd like to
invite you to shake our hands,
shake Scott's hand, and
then please leave the forge.
Come on forward, my friend.
How old are you?
18.
Hey, man, the world's yours.
I knew the bend could
have possibly happened.
He outperformed me,
and that's OK with me.
I can be outdone.
Good job.
Thank you.
I might not have
worn "Forged in Fire,"
but I have learned so
much as a bladesmith,
and I have grown as a person
doing this competition.
Scott, congratulations.
You are the "Forged
in Fire" champion,
and that is a title that comes
with a check for $10,000.
Good job, my friend.
[applause]
Thank you.
Come on forward.
Excellent.
- Thank you.
SCOTT: I won.
My blade survived.
I feel ecstatic, amazed,
however you want to say.
I hope that by doing this, I
can go full-time bladesmithing.